john lester seven and one career against
new york and john throws that good
cutter four-seam fastball change up an
occasional sinker and next up the game
one hero that's had francisco lindor
a swing and a miss and here's one of the
mets big free agent pickups during the
off-season big strong catcher james
mckinnon 2-2
paint inning over
john lester grounded a third an unhappy
hitter good start for mr lester
metz will give a spot start to robert
gazellman well this is a kudos to the
depth of this bullpen that you've got a
guy like robert gazelma now with all
these games backing up coming in to be
able to start to be his first start of
the season 14 relief appearances
schwarber over four in the opener today
one for seven in this series
and schwarber is going to hit one out
that way see
you
later oh my
halfway from the outfield wall to the
brew house
evidence
slammed their way to the lead
j max you played some center field here
we've watched a lot of games in this
ballpark i don't know if i've ever seen
a left handed better hit one up there
i'm probably speechless
my jaw's dropped
his fifth home run from the lead off
spot 444 feet above the red seats in
left center field on a changeup i've
never seen three outfielders just freeze
so fast and watch a fly ball soto has a
home run and ford bats in his career
against gazellman so a rough beginning
for robert in his first start since last
season he's as disciplined a hitter as
there is in the game 44 walks already
this year grounds went back to gazellman
a chance for two and the turn by lindor
for the 1-6-3 double play and boy did
gazellemen need that and that'll bring
up the hero of last night's game john
gomes bell at second with two out
and gomes attacks the first pitch and
lines it
right to lindor and that retires the
side the bullet off the bat of gomes
gazellman escapes with just one run
jose perazza
look at lester a little bit of this
a little bit of that and he's getting
the mets hitters to expand that plate
that's so important for john lester make
that
that make that plate span 21 inches
billy mckinney in the series hitless
yeah same pitch
battling back to get the strikeout good
cut fastball here from leicester to get
mckinney swinging sean reed foley ball
game number eight
control numbers are good but trey turner
he has already pulled one to
left turner turns on one
c
u
later
he gets his 27th multi-hit game on a big
fly and then actually do nothing a high
majestic home run 395 feet just under
100 miles an hour off the back and bobby
we've been talking about how trey is
having trouble staying back on off speed
but hey he was right on time for that
one that had serious hang time
2-2 coming to bell
and a half swing he went around on the
change-up and that's strike three so a
couple of strikeouts in the inning for
reid foley but in between trey turner
takes him deep
after three two-nothing naps john struck
out francisco first time
[Music]
short right center long way to go for a
bunch of guys and soto
who'll get there
luis garcia was running full speed but
he wasn't going to make the play
and juan soto came in
to grab it for a very big first down
soto very smoothly slides in and makes a
great play how about some t-mobile
coverage cam on this one bob you talked
about how most times center fielders are
playing on the opposite side
but robles is playing on the pool side
and
juan made a nice sweet sliding catch to
retire lindor starlin castro
one for three career against sean reid
foley the only gnats
hitter to have ever faced him
castro hard hit right field toward the
corner beyond the reach of pilar it
bounces into the bullpen it'll score one
run
and put castro
and garcia at second and third and the
nats lead three to nothing
the inning is up to kyle schwarber
schwarber
deep right center
c
u
later
he rescues the inning and puts the nats
on top by six
well this fastball not as high as the
home run that he hit off of johnny cueto
the other day
but it was a huge one for the nets
doubling their lead
niall schwarber up to 15 home runs
his rbi total is up to 38 they're loving
it above the scoreboard he has some kind
of lead off here bob wow
[Music]
he didn't get all of it relatively
speaking by the way he usually hits him
there was a little suspense at the top
of the out of town scoreboard here but
it disappeared and the nets by a bunch
beat alonso one for two today one for
four career against john lester
jammed him
it's not that deep
here comes schwarber the runner at third
is lindor and he's not going anywhere
one pitch and a nice big out for john
lester kevin pilar is next
got him
ball cutting
kevin pollard really unhappy
[Applause]
and the mets are gone in the top of the
six without scoring
they had second and third one out
and eloise rojas has to come out protect
pilar from getting tossed
let's go to the bottom of the six shall
we
here's jose perazza who has struck out
and grounded out over two
and peraza clocks one to deep left field
back toward the wall and it's out of
here jose perazo breaks up the shutout
with a two-run homer his fifth home run
of the season and the mets are on the
board in the seventh inning it's now six
to two
so the mets showing some life after
being shut out for the first six and
that's going to be all for leicester
fastball in and peraza likes it down
[Applause]
so leicester unable to finish what he
started he'll settle for six innings
plus
and it'll be a great ovation for john
lester
right hand has 13 saves and 15
opportunities taking mccann a while to
get dug in here
broken back castro hey sometimes you get
a save on one pitch and the nats win it
6-2 final
john lester
gets his first win as annette the
194th of his big league career